three cameras
good afternoon councillors members of
the public and media
welcome to the meeting start with the
council prayer
almighty god grant us all the needed
guidance
wisdom and judgment
as we face the tasks before us
and enable us now and always worthily to
discharge
the sacred trust placed by the people in
our hands
amen
[Music]
now you may notice counsellors and your
uh
agendas that there's no mere's
report
this time it's just there was so many
activities happening with three waters
plus
convert
with the new virus coming along
the race for ten percent backs
climate change
local government reform
and the smelter just
a few of the issues
that have landed on our doorstep
any apologies
uh yeshua worship councillor arnold has
rendered an apology for lateness
to be accepted any other seconded
been moved
seconded
you're sickening that counsellor safer
yes
put it to the boat all in favor say aye
uh declaration of interest are there any
changes there
no
public forum
and we did have three at one stage
didn't we claire
they come and they've gone your worship
without wishing to speak today my
understanding is that there are no
members wanting to address public forum
but we do have two late items i believe
your worship i'd like to raise a minor
late item to do with vaccination in the
community
and
and there is a major late item on the
agenda
and that relates to the manafenoua
honorarium um that's a major late item
because you do need to make a decision
and it was circulated after the agenda
had been published
and you worship just a minor league item
that councillor arnold has raised
and it's regarding just information on
the stead street stock bank
work so that's basically a briefing from
myself as chair
you wish i'm happy to move that the
major late and two minor late items be
accepted i'd have to second those
remissions moved and seconded any
discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say hi
everything's carried
move on to the minutes of the meeting of
council held on the 28th of september
i'll move those
i'll second those your worship
moved and seconded discussion questions
but it's the vote all in favor say aye
meetings carried
the minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of infrastructural services
held on the 28th of september
i will move those you worship
meeting of
insurance assurance
i'll second those your
not on the 29th of september
been moved
i know he's not
second for that
our counselor
thank you
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye again
uh there is a recommendation
from the risk and assurance thank you
malavika
i'm happy to move that recommendation
for those recommendations
now
is that item six here
all right well i wanted to abstain
on how to mine all that
and
vote no
with the second item there i think at
this stage councillor amundsen has moved
it
and has anyone seconded it and no one's
second councillor ludlow seconded it
moved and seconded it's that item one
there then that site and one end too
it's both of the recommendations from
the committee to council
happy for you to take them separately if
you would like
thank you
miners then as
um i'll abstain from that
and item two i've had against it and one
locate recorded
are you going to put the motion so the
rest of us can vote
yeah
item
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
carried
and item two
um
put it to that i'll put it to the vote
all in favor say i
i
against
no
and i'd like my
to put against now to be recorded in the
minutes it will be
i'm switching back to this
side video know your worship no it's
from
agenda minutes of the infrastructural
services committee
meeting held on the fifth of october
i'll move those you worship
second
moved in second any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carrie
minutes of the bluff community board
held on the 11th of october i'd like to
move those your worship
and move
a second or for that
i'll see who knows
i'll second those your worship
against carried
minutes of performance policy
partnerships
committee meeting held on the 12th of
october move those be received your
worship second though is your worship
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
yes
sorry bishop councillor abbott
uh just a question um clause 14 of the
performance policy and that relates of
course to the request for funding for
the lakes district
i just have a query eight confirmed
voted for the for the motion
four against then their names are tabled
and two abstained now my recollection
that makes 14 when there are 15 in
attendance i just wanted to clarify that
your worship there are two manafenua
representatives who are able to vote at
that meeting
i understand that but uh it still
doesn't equate
does now
um they could vote they they could vote
at that meeting sorry darren they could
but not at the council meeting that
wasn't a full council
that's what i'm saying it was a
performance policy where they had a
right to vote yes
i think what councillor abbott's saying
is that only 14 people's votes are
recorded there weren't
15 people in attendance to vote thank
you
so did no one abstain
to abstain
and um
ranging
[Music]
uh well apart from the obvious response
that i could make that i didn't pass
school cert maths
um
i actually just
um
i'm wondering whether everyone was
present
whether there's an apology no apologies
i understand there's no apologies
recorded i'm just wondering whether
somebody had left early or indeed
whether anybody wishes to reconsider the
minutes your worship for the purpose is
of this meeting the minutes are being
received they will be confirmed at the
ppp meeting
and councillor ludlow may wish to
consider how to deal with your question
councillor abbott at the ppp meeting but
for today
you're merely receiving them
okay thank you
good spotting council rabbit we'll keep
you on for the proofreading
thank you
um it's been moved in a second did you
manage to put that motion in your
worship point of order just for a moment
i can probably clarify uh pani's just
confirmed that she voted in favor of
that motion
so that's probably the one we're missing
thank you councillor and that may assist
councillor ludlow when he considers them
at his ppp meeting at the next
all cleared up
to the vote then call him over say hi hi
vince
yes it is and mr morris is
sitting just behind councillors to keep
an appropriate distance away
in order to present his report
good afternoon councillors this is the
final proposal
for the representation of you so this
came from the hearing of submissions
at ppp meeting
uh earlier in the month
so it is
recommending the status quo
so just to refresh everyone's memory
that is
12
councillors to be elected
at large and retain the bluff community
board within its current boundaries
so there's probably not too much else to
say this will be publicly notified
on thursday and open for appeal until
5pm on friday the 3rd of december
and any appeals that are received go
through to the local government
commission for
hearing
can say and
the last time we did this in 2015 there
weren't any
appeals um but there was always that
opportunity so as ever always happy to
answer any questions
very happy to move those recommendations
i'll second those your worship
moved and seconded you fear the
discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
move on to the bluff
tourism master plan
i'd like to move the recommendation for
all of the recommendations that you
worship um counts your worship uh i
could see rhiannon was just getting
ready to feel good it's all good yeah
i'm happy to second those in that case
your worship
it's been moved and seconded i think
bluff is going to be a major
um
aspect of the
local government and
of the tourist industry and it's good to
see a plan being formulated
at this stage
thank you worship i just think i just
think it would be a pity for us to pass
this without some words
um that acknowledged the amount of time
effort
and
good good grace from a lot of people
that has gone into producing
this plan i know we have great hopes
that
it will
deliver
a great deal for for bluff and for the
wider invercargill city council
community and i just want to acknowledge
that a lot of people have spent a lot of
a lot of time and energy bringing this
to the place we're now at
thank you for that
yes
your worship yes i have to agree with
you counselor um
um amazing a lot of work it's like
anything it's a great
it's a great plan but it will require
investment and commitment
yes well and certainly well the last
meeting i went to there they're looking
at the repairs needed on that boat
that's the oyster bait that's on display
and
it's certainly going to require
major commitment by community to
get it to its
glorious past
like to also add
the 50-plus pages and that report is
certainly worth by reading and observing
i'm sure all the councils have done so
it's a great report thank you
thank you that's okay so i'll put it to
the boat all in favor say aye aye
it's carried
working together
thank you your worship uh on behalf of
the project governance group there are
six recommendations this is a normal
monthly report just updating on progress
so pgg at its last meeting looked at um
recommendations approved by council at
the 7th of september meeting
and on the basis of that
the thompson review
on looking at phase 3 and on the way
through
just also note that pgg
also received the strategic projects
working group
closeout report which was chaired by
lindsay and this is
a follow-on from the ltp working group
was the work done
to
benchmark going forward in terms of the
way the reports
sets out
for both elt and the council
to work through a framework when dealing
with future planning
just to note that in terms of the
resolutions that the
working group
program has set out on the appendix is
being reviewed by pgg with
recommendation to come back to the
council so what we're effectively
looking at are two aspects one is that
both the cheers group and the pgg
the uh cheers role on those will be
released by the eas
before the end of this year and back to
council
and along with that
is the intention to look at
the collapsing of the last of the
working group
uh
work
and looking at whether there is a need
for one overview from a working group or
that we work that through the pgg itself
but there is a recommendation which pgg
supported
uh that there would be the continuation
of
what was the mayor and chief executives
working group to to just the support for
the
uh mayor working group and this will be
established uh on the basis of
continuing to give support to the mayor
and that will be involved with the group
of councillors which
tippity mayor has been working on
and on the basis of that i recommend the
council consider the six recommendations
for that
happy to
move those steps you'll worship actually
i'll second the new worship
thank you any discussion or questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
of business
um yes you worship there's two minor
late items you may wish to take
counsellor lush
referred to a item
yeah your worship thanks let me speak
today i i guess
what i want to ask and because it hasn't
been immediately apparent to me is that
whether council is doing everything it
can to get the vaccination numbers up
and in the cargo i just sense that
there is a complacency with distance um
and with the announcements coming
through that's going to be done by
health board by health board
it worries me that
with the very high vaccination rates in
dunedin and central otago that
invercargil and our environs can come
through with numbers in the 80s and not
in the 90s that would be desirable
professor skegg this morning on the
radio said that
scotland ireland and singapore
all have vaccination rates in their 90s
and their hospitals are inundated
with people
so even if we get to vaccination rates
of 90
bearing in mind we have an elderly
population
we spend a lot of time indoors because
of climate
and i believe that will be the overhang
for queenstown as well which is where
the
probably where the virus is likely to
appear
i think we are looking at a situation
that could really unfold badly
bearing in mind too with the last
pandemic southland's deaths were
well above the average so i'm very
concerned that with the vexathon and
things like that that
the messaging from invercargill has been
almost invisible
and i guess i wouldn't mind having a
discussion about how we can
and i don't know what the answers are
but just how we can
raise the profile
of the need to get those vaccination
rates
well into their 90s
obviously we're the furthest away from
auckland for any place
in the country but it's just moments
it's just a flight for the
virus to arrive here
and i don't know what the suggestions
are i mean we're speaking to the person
that's running
the civic they are busy they say those
that need to get the vaccines have got
them
and now it's just the apathetic
and then those that are vaccine hesitant
so i think we need to look at creative
ways that we can get people
to go and get that vaccine and the thing
is it needs to be done quite soon
um i think in a fortnight three weeks a
month it could be too late
uh you might say this is not council
business but you know
if for a level three or level four then
no one's in the library uh no one's in
the swimming pools no one's in the
shopping mall no one's doing anything so
i really think that
that i think that this council um in
combination with the
south and count the legal council needs
to think of exciting
and progressive ways that we can get the
vaccination rate
for all of us this is our first pandemic
there is no right or wrong way to do it
but i think
i've been on this council for eight
months and i haven't heard a lot of
discussion about how we need to attack
this
and i think it's probably
i mean it's the probably the most
serious preventable
disaster south has ever faced
perhaps worse than the tararua the wreck
of the tararua
so i think
i think i just like to
state the fact that i'm very worried
about
how invercargill will cope
and what we can do
to improve the outcomes of this
preventable pandemic that's coming our
way
thank you
well done congratulations
thank you worship councilor lush raises
a really good point i think there are
three levels at which we can attack it
one of those would be um to raise the
mural for him and and see if
collectively
the the
three mayors and chair
could come together and support
messaging um
we might be able to look at at how we
can incorporate messaging within
council's communications but i think
it's also
upon us each as individual community
leaders to look for opportunities to get
out
and do whatever it is we can to
encourage people towards vaccination and
i use the term encourage
because
a lot of the online rhetoric is
quite unkind um
and and i'd
personally while i'm double tapped and
keen for a third
i'm
minorly or moderately respectful of
those who choose not to be vaccinated
recognizing that some people are unable
to be
um
but at the same time
if people make the choice not to be
vaccinated then they're going to have to
accept the consequences that come with
it and that in many cases will be not
getting admission to to certain areas
events
um and and spaces
i know that as
someone who's vaccinated that doesn't
uh prevent me from catching covert i
think
the inevitability of it arriving in our
community
is is very solid
there was the light scare of blenheim at
the weekend
i would be surprised if we didn't have
cases here before christmas but it's
about giving as an immuno-compromised
person giving myself the best
opportunity and also looking after the
others
around me it doesn't
prevent transmission but it certainly
lessens it and that's where the
responsibility comes to each of us as
individuals encouraging others to do
as much as they can to try and prevent
the spread
give themselves the best chance and also
relieve the inevitable immense pressure
that's going to come on the health
system so three levels of attack if the
mural forum could discuss it if we look
for opportunities within councils
communications and if we each take up
the fight individually
thank you
counselor
i think councillor lewis might have
indicated before me
if you're happy thank you very much i'm
also very concerned about the
proliferation of potential proliferation
the um
we look at ninety percent being a target
ninety percent of five fifty thousand
is five
uh
there's a high number
because it really takes forty five no in
actual fact i'm talking about what's
left to fight the five thousand that is
left five thousand people milling around
invercargill potentially
uh a target for the the delta virus
and
that scares me and if you go back to the
80 percent
that figure's obviously rough because
you've got the children under a certain
age which who are not being vaccinated
at the moment et cetera et cetera but if
you go back to 80
that's 10 000 people just in
invercargill very loose mathematics
it is scary
uh i'm associated with a person who's uh
involved with the vaccination program
and i know she gets there early in the
morning works late at night but it has
definitely quietened down so how we
increase the
the number of people flown through the
vaccination sentence i'm not too sure
but certainly i think we should look at
it
thank you worship
thank you
thank you your worship um without
wanting to cross the boundaries of my
two responsibilities
as a icc councillor and an sdhb board
member
i just want to say i very much support
what council lush has said
i think it is
absolutely a part of this council's
responsibility to see if we can
encourage in any way possible
more vaccinations to be taken up
the sdhb does have a
reasonably good record of vaccinations
but we can certainly get that even
higher
i do just want to say that
there has been some advertising that
your two fellow mayors
mir hicks and
mia tong
in the fortnight's time
are going to have a large push i believe
that they are taking out caravans into
their local areas
i do wonder whether that means it has
already been discussed at the mural
forum and that perhaps it is time that
invercargill city council rolled out our
own
consultation caravan
either loaning it to your fellow mirrors
or using it ourselves in some creative
way
just as an extra little bit of a
publicity push
and
and that perhaps we ask if staff can
look at
some
um addition to our
icc website to make it clear that we are
a council who supports
vaccination
i think any anything that we can do to
help the
the um situation
the the country as a whole recognizes
just how serious this is and with the
chair of the bluff community board
sitting in our gallery i'm sure none of
us have forgotten
that quite by accident bluff of course
was the um
the epicenter for a while um in the
first round and what that emphasises is
that at any point
at all
some unexpected part of new zealand can
have the one person or the couple of
people who visit
who bring this
disaster with them
so i'm certainly very
very much
enthused to encourage anything this
council can do to support the ongoing
campaign
thank you
thank you
ansel clark
just to reinforce a lot my colleagues
are saying um just some simple numbers
because i like numbers as you know
um the 90 only it only relates to those
that are available to have the uh
vaccinations so that leaves us in new
zealand with um 500 000 people
unvaccinated but if you put the children
on top of that we've got another 500
thousands we've got a million so that's
20 of our population unprotected so it's
no good talking about auckland but on
south and wide
um that means if you affected in 20
percent of our population here
being unprotected you're talking about
24 000 people in southam
so that's a really scary figure as
marcus and others have said
um
and if one percent of that 20 percent
which is a really small figure
getting affected by covert our hospital
systems won't cope just one percent of
the 20
so it's scary when you start looking at
figures a lot and modeling like that i
notice up north or certainly down here
we seem to be a little bit blase that
we're a long way away from auckland
which is the epicenter so you can see
how uh
far north um
western bar plenty and waikato have sort
of upped the ante as it were done a
whole lot more because they're scared of
the impact and we're a little bit blase
back here we haven't had a covered scare
for a long long time
but that as marcus quite rightly says
you do that at your peril because by the
time you need it it's too late
um so and some of the ones up north
around the christchurch region and some
around dunedin have had fun days
they get music groups in that appeal to
some of these younger people the biggest
risk group from what the
deputy director of health said was
recently
was the 19 to 29 year olds that group
they are quite blase about it all
there's a high level of antibiotics here
but there are a high level of people say
ah won't affect us we're healthy
um and that's the people we need to get
to and you don't get to them by putting
things on icc websites they won't even
be internet we've got to find other
mediums to get to them
music is one way
and facebook and other places are other
ways so whether we
listen to the advice and look at the
results we've got from other councils
that have got on had fun days
over a weekend where we
strike a couple of sunny days
and go out and vex i know the other two
councils that are going out from the
mural forum are more focused on outlying
areas so they've got communities that
are well out and they're looking to
enhance the delivery there so ours is
more condensed because we've got a local
population that's pretty close
so maybe we should
uh somewhere along the line have a very
short workshop on what initiatives we
might be able to take to get these young
people in these when i say young these
sort of 18 to 29 year olds
we can capture them and we can um
piggyback on the initiatives that are
going for ewie that would take us into a
much better position
thank you counselor cricket
thank you worship um you can hear me
okay
yes cool um so i have been following a
little bit about some of the initiatives
across the country that um are getting a
bit of attention that are just a little
bit out of the box um around this
because like my colleagues have said i
think it's absolutely something that we
should be looking at as well it's our
collective responsibility we are all
leaders in the community
um and i wondered if perhaps the um like
council of clark has just said the one
going going to the people
that can't come to us is i think really
something for us to focus on because you
know that's where we're seeing
uh lesser uptake rates and i wondered um
auckland has a shot bus
they're calling it shop bro and it's a
bus that they've got nurses on and they
go out to the community on the bus
rather than having the community come to
them and thought perhaps it could be
something that we look at
thank you
well there's certainly a lot of ideas
coming forward and now we've
got to try and implement them i'm in
favor of a video film type type of
approach and um tip top seems to be
used a lot lately they might be spying
on us but
um
they still do a good job in terms of
communication and getting through to the
young people
no more
as a resident dance routine person you
worship
you'd be the first person who's familiar
with how to
bust some moves for tick
tock might be time to bust the costume
back out
maybe a former committee to look into it
um
no more speakers on it thank those who
put forward their ideas and they'll put
it to the voice all in favor you wish if
there is no doubt there's nothing oh i'm
not even receiving it
no
no
you've had a discussion and there was no
emotion
all right we move on to each and
business thing uh the second item
is a second minor item in relation to
state street
thank you worship look this is um
really a briefing for all councillors
and an update and it's sort of been
triggered by councillor arnold sent an
email out to councillors this morning
and just seeking clarity
about road dimensions and widths and
why why one lane and why cycle lane so
um
we've got here available for all
councillors later and the media is an
actual
uh scale drawing of the plant stockpile
the sheet piling plant and the road
widths that it takes up but just to give
you an idea
currently both lanes
in and out of tara
take up
7.35 meters there's a pullover lane
by the airport roughly two and a half
metres wide and there's a new built up
area
that you'll see with gravel and
everything that's about 1.8 meters wide
so the area needed for the for the plant
for the sheep piling plant
is actually seven meters
so it basically takes up all of the
known road out to odata that's laned
so what we're doing is we're creating
one lane into odatara on solid roadway
and the new built up area will create a
1.5 meter
pedestrian
cycle lane
now you might ask the question why is
our pedestrian cycle lane important well
we operate and all councils operate on
the copton traffic management guidelines
so councils and all their contractors
have to abide by the rules that
if there is in place
a cycle
lane walk lane
then and you take it out of action you
have to provide an alternative
so we are only following the rules that
we expect all contractors to abide by
now access to the airport is both way
and access out about ataro will be via
as as already stated
odata road and current road which lead
on to bay road
now what else we got here now the sheep
piles that are being driven in to the
seabed at 12 meters long
now they're going to have to be
trucked in and then maneuvered into
place
in this area
and then driven home so this is
it's pretty serious stuff
um what else we got here so uh we've got
a
we've got a uh this brochure here is
being mailed out unfortunately we got
caught up with um
the long weekend but that is arriving
everyone's
house and there's information being
given to the school kids and we have a
on thursday between 5 30 and 7
a drop in session at the
odata school hall so
that's i just thought i'd update
everyone on that so just to get those
details out out which i think some
people have seen for the first time
yeah yeah so we've got copies over here
and then we've got a drop-in session on
thursday
so thanks for have time
can i ask a question
yes
um
yes sir counselor is that information
package going out to all ratepayers or
just over tara
otatra is getting it all yes sorry not
to invercargil ratepayers
okay thank you it will be available
through social media on our website
and in other channels that we use but
we're not mailing it to all ratepayers
thank you any questions discussion
i know i just want to uh thank chelsea
information that's very cool to me
because the big fear the
information that we've had after so far
is
because we were told initially that took
up
one night not required
so of course it doesn't it's not too
hard to work out
that there's actually two other lines
really near available which is
why i was actually questioning in the
first place i'm interested to see you uh
see this picture here when i can
yep
okay it's cool
oh sorry cancel it
as a reflection of what alan's just said
i guess and this is just a reflection on
i guess the way we've dealt with this it
seems to people in the otara that um
the decision had been made and there'd
be no consultation before that
and i struggle with that i think one of
the learnings from this is that we need
to
be more respectful of our communities
that if i was to go and save room take
close off or
make some major inroads into the
road leading to bluff and didn't talk to
bluff people about it first even if it
wasn't a position where they could
change at least they'd be advised
because otherwise you get a storm that
we've now got where people are talking
about all kinds of crazy stuff
so um yeah i think that's my reflection
on that thank you
uh yes just um through mr me
can you please be noted that neither
ms koto or i received that email so we
weren't aware that there was even a
question about this
thank you
it was sent out by councillor arnold
himself yes oh yeah sorry that that yeah
councillor arnold probably does not have
in your
um
correct your worship
okay
and we now have a major nate item which
is the report on honorarium
okay and that was on a separate sheet
it's
yes it's in the board books for all
councillors
yes
[Music]
honorarium um and mr morris is again
ready to
present the report
good afternoon again
so you
so the first uh thing to
that's been corrected you'll just notice
in the report at the recommendations
that it was uh that the performance
policy and partnerships committee um
make some decisions unfortunately that
hadn't saved when we had done the report
it should be the council which is shown
correctly up there so i just wanted to
point that out when you were looking at
your report that that was something that
unfortunately had not saved so
uh it's further through that this is the
basis of where we have got to on the
issue of the manufa honorarium and
you'll see there are three
uh recommendations that have been put up
as alternatives
um we have explored with the urunaka
chief executives and managers whether a
hourly rate would be an appropriate
means
there was wide agreement that that
becomes quite
uh
burning some for the representatives
filling those uh hourly rates in but
also for
uh the staff uh
council processing those so it was felt
that a flat fee was a better approach
for
them uh there are then the
three options
there so the minimum allowable
councilor salary rate um
set by the enumeration authority is
thirty four thousand six hundred and
sixty seven dollars uh some councils
have and their amount of no
representatives adopted that as their
enumeration or honorarium level
uh
the original amount was uh has been
rounded nicely to twenty thousand
dollars
that was calculated on the basis of
approximately 10 hours a week
[Music]
for council meetings and that included
workshops and the necessary preparation
for it
and then the plus or minus
on top of that
the third option is at the midway point
between those uh two options
uh so that rounds out at twenty seven
thousand
uh dollars as a
compromise uh solution between a full
council of enumeration reflecting that
um the manifesto representatives are not
councillors and do not have their um
ongoing obligations of re-election every
three years but that they do have a
fulsome role to play at council
and the honorarium needs to be set at a
at a level that reflects the money and
dignity that they that the roles bring
to
council
that is important that dorunaka's
preferred position was the
council of enumeration at 34 000
but and
that is a run through of my report
i as ever remain happy to answer
questions
thank you i've got three issues i wish
this arsenal i hope you don't take
offense being here is not easy for you
to listen to some of this
um the three issues for me are who do
the monophenol represent because that
dictates the value the volume and value
of the work
the second issue is
where's our nearest comparison
that we should be looking at
and thirdly is the issue of the what do
these actual honorariums actually mean
so do the first part first
i've noticed in this document and in a
previous document
that there is discussion about
the manafenua appointees speaking on
behalf of the wider ewe group and when
i've asked several times what does that
actually mean do they have a mandate to
speak on behalf of mata waka
i don't get a steady response from that
in fact the last response i got from
staff
indicated that that was a work in
progress and that and i said so progress
from what end
to d
go out and discuss with the other wider
ewe group about whether they'll have
their voice or not
and the response was that the council
would do that so i'm not sure
how council can facilitate that given
that from one meeting to the next we
have individual papers where we want to
hear any uh monophenol voice
and so that wider group and how we
capture those or whether we actually
capture them are still an open question
for me
the other issue is looking at
what's paid in other places and so
the obvious one that's very similar to
us is environment canterbury so they've
got
appointees on on their councils
and in true partnership with naitahu
naitar who pays half the fee
and council paid the other half feet
and so i wonder why we haven't
approached naitahu about that given that
partnerships are about not just us
wanting to hear their voice but them
wanting to be
part of our group as well
and so to me that's the only firmed up
one that we've got environment south and
have some roles on their committees
and they're paid at 75
per day half day and 150 dollars per
full day which i think is
way way too low for what what you're
asking for
so i'll come back to the figures about
um and i appreciate the last report it's
got a schedule in there by michael that
says
what the projected input will be
from these appointees over the next 12
months so it's about 10 hours a month
um so when i do some quick calculations
on what the options are that we can pay
for that for that input given that he
considers the meetings
and the time to prepare for the meetings
these are the figures that i come up for
so if we have
a
honorarium that matches a full council
thing that works out at two hundred and
twenty eight dollars per hour
and if you extrapolate that out to a
full time position that's six hundred
thousand dollars per year
so you can imagine what my view of that
is
option d which is the 70 percent rate
works out at 225 per hour
nine thousand dollars per week
468
000
per annum
both those hourly rates are higher than
the chief executive of this organization
so uh to me that's way too high so my
preference
is for option b which is 50 percent of
the rate
and if naita
leadership and the two runangas think
that's inadequate they should do what
they do which is what the tribe does in
canterbury and they should top it up
and so that's my view of the figures so
my personal preferences for option b
council
thank you
thanks your worship
we're in a
an interesting honeymoon period in in uh
relationship with with manafenoua
and it's it's unfortunate that
so early on uh
we have to start with with money it's
it's an uncomfortable discussion
but i also think it's it's not a great
way to start a relationship that is a
little overdue
um
by going low
um
i think the words that uh that mr morris
used
uh in his report
um and in uh in chambers this afternoon
talked about recognizing
the manner
of of the relationship
and and in my mind that sits at either
option c or a
not necessarily at b
i i kind of understand what counselor
clark is trying to do by breaking it
down to an hourly rate but that actually
is is kind of a smoke and mirrors and
off to the side thing because there's
not an hourly rate being presented
as an option and and
i guess the comparisons would
with with other positions would would
show
why
so the manafenoua representatives don't
necessarily have have a vote at a full
council
but they
certainly are able to contribute
um i don't think there's a vote either
at risk and assurance but
there's a lot of um
of meetings of both the infrastructural
services and performance policy and
partnerships committee and extraordinary
meetings and workshops that easily make
up that 10 hours a week that mr morris
referred to
and and frankly i'd i'm just more
comfortable starting at option c it's a
steep learning curve to get on at the
beginning uh and councillor lush will
recognize that coming in um almost two
thirds of the way through the turn
there's there's a lot of getting up to
speed and a lot of
not just digesting the information that
we've got already but having to get the
context of it
um from staff as well so
um
that's where i'm leaning at the moment
sir
and
if you're looking for
someone to make a recommendation
or do you want
discussion to continue first
i'd like to see discussion continue
thank you then i'll i'll not make a
recommendation at this point
thank you your worship i was going to
actually make a recommendation to try
and start the ball rolling and i'll
explain why i was going to do that
because
as councillor ludlow has just referred
to i think that we can over analyze the
situation in monetary and economic terms
and forget
the actual groundbreaking um
representation that we and relationship
that we have tried to establish here
by making the decision to have our
marathon or representatives at this
table
i think that
what counselor clark has tried to do in
extrapolating into hourly rates
is moving far away from the basis of
what the relationship is actually about
and i i really don't want to explore
that track any further except perhaps to
say that if you if you're going to start
down that track then you're merely
inviting calculations of the hourly
rates of every person around this table
and it becomes a totally pointless
exercise
in terms of the the relationship
building that that these appointments
are all about
and bearing in mind the fact that this
is only for a 12-month period and that
there is the chance in that 12 months
for all the positive extra things to be
established such as how the relationship
with mata waka is going to work
and how we decide um with
our representatives
is the best way in which that
consultation can take place
i think in line of the fact that we do
have the local body elections next year
and the chance to look again at the
remuneration
that i would like to put forward this
recommendation with option c in place
so i'm moving the recommendation and the
second one be we approve the honorarium
to be option c
um
do you want to still finish your
resolution cancelling that lag or sorry
did you just move i just moved options
i'm happy to see him thank you
good counselor
through the chair i'm just seeking some
clarification on the decision
this council is making today realizing
that um
in a year's time uh we will have a new
council and an inaugural meeting
uh so mr morris um come that inaugural
meeting
uh is is there a reset does the new
council
uh have to then appoint the two new
seats or are they
in place now that we've done that
so the seats are in place the appointees
will be reappointed at the inaugural
meeting no that's good i just need
clarification on that and then thus the
remuneration would carry on
that your enumeration would be reset at
that stage
reset or just carry on from what it is
what we do today no it would be a new
discussion for the full council new
council term right now that's that's i
just needed clarification on that on
what we are deciding on today
um the other
the other
suggestion i may have is that uh is it
worthwhile this council
uh constructing a letter to the minister
of local government
to
maybe seek
advice and this is for consistency
nationwide from the remuneration or
authority
uh on this matter because we are not
everyone is facing this dilemma i know
dunedin have have come up with a formula
um
so
i'm just wondering whether council would
seek an additional
note to the
recommendations that we do right
to the minister asking
if
she would get
the remuneration authority to look into
some consistency throughout the country
because i believe it deserves it
and then we're not going to be sitting
here
um doing this exact thing
in the future for the next councils
you worship i wonder if um councillor
partners suggestion which has a lot of
merit i mean i think the remuneration
authority
could help provide some consistency but
whether that would have more weight if
it came through lg z um with with all
councils seeking the same thing um
whether that might be an effective way
of getting the outcomes not going to be
quick obviously
i like the idea that's being one of the
first off the ground but
yes
yes i favor option c um
i think the fact that we're debating it
now sounds mean-spirited i know when the
discussion originally was um
when michael went to they
they were offered from my understand the
role of full council and they said that
no that they were happier with this role
so there must have been the money in the
budget for them to be full councils
anyway
that's my understanding
maori ward
mary ward which would have which would
have been a full council which would
have been a full remuneration for
councils they're up for that anyway i
think to go back on that now they're
doing as much work and i think it also
runs the risk of undermining the
excitement that we had here several
months ago we welcome these reps here to
now
quibble about how much they're going to
get paid um especially on the you know
on the fact that we are embarking on a
50 million more like i it just seems
that the amounts and the discussion
for it seem to be um
out of tune with what just should be for
me a slam dunk that they get paid the
right of the council they do as much and
um
i think to do anything apart from that
would be to undermine
the excitement and the historic
significance of having
those reps on the council
all right well i seek you your worship
oh sorry i didn't see you as the mover
of the recommendations
i would be comfortable to add a
recommendation three
that this council
writes to the minister
and to lgnz
that would be an amendment but it's not
um
contradicting the origin no it's not
your worship as the second or i'm
comfortable with that being added your
worship
so we would be writing to the minister
to ask the minister
to investigate with the
commission
but and we would be writing to gnz to
raise the matter
for our gnz policy consideration
would that hold up the process no it
wouldn't your worship that's why i'm
phrasing it this way
well of course i'm going for the a for
the top
because of the recognition that i think
tango topena will be playing a major
role in
an investment
in the south island and they've proven
to be a
very astute
developers and
i think a lot of our future will be
dictated by
um this new
arrival announced
and
um i know i'll lose but
it sounds like you have a chance of
getting halfway the recommendation is
approve the honor room to be midway
you just put a line
can i sorry i think i said um that i've
went for c i went for a sorry as long as
it was
that's fine but i'm just going to ask
malavika to make it clear that
at the moment
yes please
what you are debating is the motion of
27 000
i think just a
headliner cancel ups for
[Music]
minimalist
reward or
input
i mean we've just come such a long way
in terms of race relations in this
country
and
without seeing land marches and
occupations and
have to
scale that we did in the
80s
and i think it's good for the country to
carry on
that positive approach
you alright yes thank you worship
so i'll put it to the vote are you all
clear what the amendment was and
just put it to the vote all in favor say
aye
aye again
no
where are you i'm against the 27.
oh wow
division
area of the division falls law
those in favor
can i so i've become very confused with
the process
so counsellor what's happened is that um
there is a motion that the manafenoua
remuneration be twenty seven thousand
dollars that was tabled by
that was moved by councillor sopa
and seconded by councillor ludlow
because
of
the number of people indicating they are
against that amount a division has been
called forth so i will now ask that all
those in favor
of 27 000 please raise their hand
uh yes i see you counselor crackit thank
you i think there are five in favor
councillor sopa lewis amundsen
cracker
ludlow have i missed any vote in favour
those against
just a point of order there how do you
distinguish
between the ones who are against who
wants 20 option c
or option a oh sorry option b so first
you vote this motion down until you vote
it down
right
this is the only motion on the table
okay yep so there will be a chance for
the next yeah
not necessarily
there is a chance that nothing will
happen nobody indicated the wish for an
amendment before this motion was put to
the vote i just as in a point of order i
potentially thought that each you know
the simplest way would have been how
many for a how many for b how many
percent i'm sorry counselor then c was
moved
and no and no amendment was sought
right
hence we are here amen
no there was an expression but nobody
used the words i would like to move an
amendment
so for my benefit can you just clarify
who's in favor at the stage i believe
that in this stage i have counsellors
louis
sopa ludlow amundsen and crackit voting
in favour thank you
i'd like to ask those against because
there may be some abstentions
those against
thank
you and i believe there are eight
councillors voting against
councillors clark arnold lush kept
pottinger scout
abbot and his worship the mayor
she's lost so you declare
the motion lost
your worship
can we put forward another motion then
can we put forward option 8
can we move option a worship
all right
i'll move that
i've moved it you can second it
counselor
okay it's moved and seconded go to
counsellor
to say aye aye
and
your worship
what is
we're down to two now what is uh could
someone just read out what an option
so
the
amendment that has been moved and i
actually see andrew and michael just
having a conversation
you're comfortable with this gentleman
right is that counsellor sopa and i
wonder about that because the council of
sofa moves the original motion
uh it was defeated
uh has moved
a
that the honorarium be equal to the base
council of remuneration and councillor
abbott seconded it
and that is what is now being voted on
could all those in favor please raise
their hand
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
nine in favor
and those against
one two three councillors kent clark and
arnold
and are you against your worship
you haven't raised your hand
if it helps your worship um
you did talk in favor of that option
yes
what was it again
let the remuneration be equal to base
council a remuneration of 34 000.
10 in favor three against
so what's the final
that motion is carried
thank you
answer this
move on to
in committee
yes you worship that
that brings us to the end of the public
agenda
i'll move we go into public excluded
with the exception of mr grant and mr
mckenzie your worship second
accumulation and the two
manifestos
and the two male female wreaths
that's best we could fit up members of
the community board
category
[Applause]
thanks for your attendance
you